hello way to welcome to this video
against OT pop again I had a interesting
game against him yeah yeah I missed some
I I missed some shots and so I'm curious
to see how this this unfolds Wow
interesting interesting stuff I really
don't know this line this blackest white
castle long here actually or not mean it
looks like the right thing to do USD
five coming here probably yes Black is
very well developed so probably d5
coming and so what do I play here
you
hmm not sure to do simple move like f3
is probably not doing all that much
after takes Knight X my bishop is
misplaced down hmm mylar pieces in
general are not very well placed yeah I
should play something f4 also doesn't
look right ok let's do this it looks
extremely slow and it doesn't play any
file I'm worried to no end that the d5
is played ok ok yeah I kind of just
wanted to go here but let's check on e3
that doesn't actually work at least not
easily so a just place normal stuff yeah
my position is not harmonious and I'm
down two minutes and it just places in
all news and I don't know stuff
no GG three wins material now let's
let's issue I'm not an experienced you
for play and sometimes they playoff bid
lines that are probably not all that
great but I haven't looked at them and
my what I know is this is not enough
sometimes I mean like know from from
kind of general things I actually wanted
to play g6 but okay maybe this is
actually not that uninteresting ik it
takes this lance yeah probably i'm just
getting checkmated here get a Bishop to
c4 I mean maybe I'm again maybe I'm
getting checkmated so Queen a five but
again this is not a maid so let's put
this him
you will go to e6 hmm probably this is
better
how do you defend against Queen g7 now
I'm pretty curious about it this one ok
so can just stick in teenage sense not
that clear actually let's crazy
can take age seven minutes not that
clear hi morning yeah i know crazy
sometimes my ideas routine one group
takes five or something like that i mean
i can give this check anyway so and now
it's going to Brooks you or not okay I
control a eight but maybe he has some
other made cap remove the night is made
on f7 group c 7 s 28 mate what is he
going to do now to trick me somehow here
you can see a Claver move here to black
don't see a move
come up with the night and yes no way to
bring the hook over on da phone so he
wants to make a draw check check it
probably is a draw Bishop c4 maybe look
ain't made ok let's not do that but I
can take d sexy as well question is to
set win she have to take the draw check
check check check check game draw no man
no really probably i can win something
with something yet it was a good good
try can just take the room yeah take the
hook if what you say I'm such an idiot
yeah but 40 seconds on the clock and
don't see this look we know what they
saw this that also wins but because i'm
covering this and just you know this is
very easy ah as every sick of this i had
to complete wins against this guy with
this was meeting a text and didn't
didn't finish both yeah well the opening
result was terrible but yeah here I
expected d5 of course and this is better
than the six and this is why it took me
so long here I didn't really find a move
that I liked I looked his six that's
something wow that's pretty strong
stockfish he cannot move anything now
ready and here I've got the sacrifice
cap very strong wow I can't hear you
didn't play define pretty signal g6
which is of course not bad but I was
more concerned about d5 and T i had the
sisters I'm just playing this badly he
had he had the smooth i was thinking i
have this this is this between age 3 it
was a bit of a bluff but it's not so
easy to do bring the Queen 283 and hope
for the best what he did is fine I mean
he sees much better anyway until he was
still playing all those instant moves
and not not trying to finish it off d 5
was very good Getty I wanted to play g6
but maybe this was better here I'm
starting to doubt that this is so great
I mean here black wind self with with
best player that's kind of clear yes the
attack I have nothing but I wonder if
this is correct him that that that gives
me more space for the king and the
bishop to see form so this and I think
the engine is already not quite sure
what's going on and now I'd find
something for black again jam that
position is really so bad that there are
multiple ways ways to finish me off 96
yeah surprisingly he he didn't play 96
and no no wide winced sorry but I'm just
amazingly bad with finishing things off
um
Bishop g5 already was winning this is
kind of getting something similar yeah
for and clock that's it basically and
just have like Queen edge it now don't
ask me then the main thing was actually
I expected I didn't expect any move that
they put some kind of problem and queen
if I would have seen it before hand I
think it was an chances to to find
something good against that I mean many
things win this is a draw 30 seconds
then I need to practice tactics but I
don't don't know when I should do that
okay anyways thanks for watching